as podcast has bad words hello everybody
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist welcome to episode 129 today
we're gonna talk about the details of
the science oh I brought the wrong notes
for Gigi gah gah gah yeah but I feel bad
making fun of her oh no I think it was
all an elaborate prank on her part maybe
I even I think she was trying to get a
lot of YouTube views and it worked out
really really well really yeah I don't
know I can find that she was like legit
skits oh maybe I don't know I don't know
man but but I thought she I thought it
was like an elaborate prank and anyway
it was it was she did a great job we are
not going to talk about the details of
the science today today we're gonna talk
about starting anew we're gonna talk
about new beginnings we're gonna talk
about starting over and everything that
that entails Before we jump into that
Ryan you you've had an interesting week
you had your your cysts in town yes she
had a bit of a it's almost like
sometimes we need a kickstart to have a
new beginning I it's the one thing that
is interesting for me I I feel like we
often put these arbitrary new beginnings
I mean remember back in the sales world
it was like well it's the it's a new
month and now we have these new sales
goals we're starting a new and and that
can be okay I mean it can make us feel
like it's a reset but it is arbitrary
right and once we realize that it
becomes a bit of a really small
superpower to realize like oh wow like
today is is April 24th and I can just
reset today I don't have to wait until
May 1st or June 1st or the first of the
year for the new year's resolution it's
you know it's time for spring cleaning
right now so to speak we can do that in
our homes we can also do it in our own
bodies and minds as well yeah absolutely
man waking up every day and looking
looking at it as an opportunity to to
reset you know it's funny man I have
been with my blood sugar being all weird
like in the morning
is where i'm the grumpiest yeah and it's
funny because I use that technique of
looking at it as like a new beginning
I'm like here's my chance to take this
grumpiness that I have and not project
it out of my body and I can start
practicing this every day and and you
know it's it's working so far but
usually like as soon as I get like some
coffee and me or bulletproof especially
bulletproof coffee and me I'm like I'm
totally good to go you doing some carbs
in the morning too though right no
really no no I mean if like if it's uh
what's been the most helpful for you
because you've talked about this a
little bit on the podcast for those you
don't know Ryan
found out that he was pre-diabetic even
though he had a great lifestyle but it
wasn't great enough and so you've made
some changes what's helped the most
um cutting out rice potatoes bread I
don't I don't here's what I used to
always do man I go to a restaurant I'd
order something and it come with like
delicious potatoes or bread or if they
bring the bread to your table before the
meal yeah and instead of me saying oh I
don't want that take it back because
that's not how I am at a restaurants
like it takes it would have to be a
really really terrible meal for me to
like send anything back mm-hmm so I'm
just like all right I'll leave it on the
table but then sure enough I'm like I'll
just have a bite I'll just have two
bites and then next thing you know I'm
like alright tomorrow I'm gonna stop
eating all these carbs today is gonna be
my last day and I just had a lot of
those days I did that with ice cream
I did that with bread and I just want to
say too like there's nothing wrong with
bread ice cream or you know whatever
potatoes or rice it's just it's a
problem for me because I'm just
genetically predisposed ish n''d
to not handle those those carbs well
there's a fast-burning carbs well yeah
so for me like cutting that stuff out is
really up I'm not advocating this for
all of our listeners um but but that's
well it's helped me bring my levels down
but I think I talked about this on the
podcast it it has helped me see though
how sugar sugar masks like this this
symptom of hey
hmm Haan ger like it's a totally an
alcohol is the same exact thing so like
once I've taken those fast-burning carbs
out and drastically reduced my intake of
alcohol mm-hmm
like I just noticed like oh like there
are these symptoms coming up and I think
it comes through I think with hangar
anyway
yeah well it's fascinating that we have
a diet question here we'll get to so
maybe we'll pick that back up with the
diet question here later in in the
podcast but I have a lot of questions
and in comments about that as well with
respect to my own life but questions for
you that I think will help shed some
light for our audience as well which by
the way I just got my blood checked and
again again and alright so I was for the
third time in six months or yes the
third time in six months I got my blood
checked the first time it came back at I
want to say it was like 7.1 which is
diabetic mm-hm and that's when dr. Ryan
green was like we need to retest you
because this doesn't seem right cuz I
told him what I was just telling you
about you know here are the exceptions I
make in my diet here's here's what I do
to splurge and he was like no dude like
how many doughnuts are you eating a week
right like it's almost like he didn't
believe you right as it wasn't
consistent that the blood results you
had weren't consistent with mine eyne
with what what you said your diet was
now he'd also didn't know about the the
genetic history and rent from your
father and grandfather etc right so I
got retested it came back at 6.1 or 6.4
so yeah maybe 6.4 which was basically
like on the close to being diabetic and
then I just got it back and now it's 5.7
and what I'm talking about is my
hemoglobin a1c which is just an
indicator of how much sugar you've had
in your body it's an average over the
last 90 days but just from changing my
diet over the last month has like taken
it down another point four points so 5.7
on the hemoglobin you know scale mm-hmm
I am basically if I can get down to so
I'm at 5.7 yeah if I can get down to 5.6
nine so if I get down
one thousandth or I'm sorry one
hundredth of a percent yeah then I will
be I will be considered non-diabetic not
even like like right now I'm in that
range where it's like pre-diabetic but
if I can just get it one more hundreds
of away yeah I will be no done I will be
non-diabetic fried cupcakes that's right
Dean that's right man no it's funny make
is like when I got that number back I
really did want to go out and start
splurging like I went out and I was like
oh I'm gonna like do this I'm gonna do
that and oh wow so that's it and then
all of a sudden I was well because
here's the thing is like I was making
exceptions like the last month month and
a half when we were especially when we
were on tour I was made I was making
these deceptions with like I'm gonna
have a bite of this or I'm gonna have a
I'm gonna have you know another glass of
wine instead of just sticking to one
glass of wine and I was kind of doing
that to see what where my blood would be
and it turns out it has actually gone
down so yes like all of a sudden I
wanted to be like oh it's going down
that means I can add more to my diet but
then quickly I was able to reason with
myself and be like dude like I've built
some really good habits it's very like I
don't crave sugar as much I don't crave
the bread as much and if I start I do
have those cravings don't get me wrong
but not nearly as often as when I was
eating it on a more regular basis so
yeah I was able to quickly kind of turn
myself around and be like alright - like
don't undo everything you've done over
the last you know over the last few
months
so getting those test results back
prompted a new beginning for you the
first time you got the test results back
because you're like obviously some
changes need to happen here right yeah I
mean my life depended on it exactly and
I think also I wasn't thinking about
this going into the episode but what's
fascinating I got these this good good
news back and now I'm going to go start
at least my mindset is well I'm gonna go
celebrate now right yeah and so a new
beginning isn't necessarily a good
convinient have a new beginning that's
like I can think back to my mom you know
she was an alcoholic and she quit a
bunch she quit drinking a bunch of times
and honestly when I was growing up the
things the times that were most
terrifying for me was when she was sober
mmm because you knit was just like a
matter of time I knew that if I know I'm
seven years old
I come home to the house on Warren
Street which we were just back at
recently filming the the new documentary
there and it's all boarded up now but I
would come home I'd open the door and I
wouldn't know whether or not she was
going to be on the couch passed out with
you a beer on the floor you know bottle
of wine or something or if she was gonna
be sober that day and every single day
it was like I was I was spinning the
roulette wheel and it just had young but
it was gonna land on black or red that
day and and so there were times where
was actually more terrifying because I
didn't have the the I had the
uncertainty of know what what's today
going to be like whereas if she was on
you know several week-long bender like
at least I knew what to expect I'd come
home and she'd be passed out on the
couch and and so in a weird way like
sometimes the new beginnings were her
like falling off the wagon again and
starting to drink that was a unfortunate
new beginning but that's not what we
want to talk about today what we what we
want to talk about today is how do we
have the good new beginnings how do we
start anew because we're in a position
where we want to make some changes in
our life so I love that dude so the next
time I have the urge to I don't eat a
cake can remember less I may have eaten
a whole cake I'm sure I've done it
before but the last time I get in order
to do that like I've got to ask myself
like do I want this to be my new
beginning do I do I want to start a new
beginning right now and start
implementing this bad habit back into my
life I love that dude it's a really good
way of looking at it how about we dive
into some of these voicemails I darris
our first one today our first voice
mails from Lexie in Cincinnati so my
husband and kids and I are planning on
moving to Seattle or Portland in the
next year and we're trying to figure out
which stuff would be beneficial to keep
first of sell and I know you guys are
doing a big move so I wanted to see what
your input is on this and to kind of get
rid of everything that we have that
clutter but you know the big pieces of
furniture where we do all right so so I
can't tell you what to do specifically
Lexie but I can tell you what I would do
if I were in your situation first off
congratulations your move
you're moving from one great city
Cincinnati Ohio which Ryan and I worked
in for many years and you're moving up
to the Pacific Northwest a either
Seattle or Portland and two other just
wonderful cities so so congratulations
but there's gonna be a total change
there they're completely different
cities all three of them are are
different I mean obviously Portland and
Seattle are a little bit more similar
than than Cincinnati but they are
definitely different places so first on
our website recently I wrote this essay
it was very very short and it was called
questions to ask before purchasing and
so I've got six questions here that I
often ask myself either directly or
indirectly before purchasing the first
question is who am i buying this for or
if Sean were correcting me he would say
for whom am i buying this because ending
a sentence for the preposition is
something up with which he will not put
but he's very descriptive
prescriptivists and that way but uh
who-who am i buying this for it is a
question in and I think when we're
thinking about holding on to our stuff
we can ask that question right like who
is this actually for who am i holding
onto this for am I just trying to
impress other people with this huge DVD
collection who is that really impressing
I know that's what impresses me you come
over you're like big giant DVD
collections Josh you have a huge DVD
collection so who am i buying this for
maybe who am i keeping this for is this
something that that the Who am I trying
to impress yeah who am I trying to
impress now if it's truly for you then
maybe we move on to the next question
will this add value to my life now what
do I mean by that I mean will it serve a
purpose or bring you joy there's several
purposes it useful is some sort of tool
or is it a piece of artwork on the wall
that you truly get joy from or is it in
the way the average American household
has 300 thousand items in it most of
those things get in the way of the
things that truly add value to our lives
as as a minimalist the paradox of
minimalism is I get far more value from
the few items I have than if I were to
water them down
three hundred thousand other items the
third question I ask myself is can I
afford it now if I have to put something
on a credit card then I can't afford it
when I'm purchasing something right
mm-hmm what if I don't have the space
for it well then I certainly can't
afford it right because I had to put in
a storage locker a basement or somewhere
but can I afford it as a question now
maybe here's the question for you Lexie
and for your family can we afford
holding on to this or with selling that
thing actually bring more money that we
can do something else with right the
fourth question that I asked myself is
is this the best use of this money so
before I buy something is this the best
use of this money and so if I'm holding
on to something maybe that question is
is this the best use of this resource of
the time and attention necessary to take
care of the thing but also is this the
is this the the best item that in fact
quite often will realize like we have
closed as an easy example for me because
I had way too many clothes when I first
started simplifying that's where I
started I realized like oh the these
aren't even the best clothes meaning
they're not my favorite clothes not my
favorite thing so maybe if I reposition
that question for old on the stuff is
are these my favorite things right the
the fifth thing that I ask myself is
what's the actual cost of this thing not
just a price tag because the price
though the price goes way beyond the
price tag right yeah there's so many
other costs the cost of fixing the thing
and taking care of the thing and putting
gas in the thing and changing things oil
what about the batteries for the thing
and storing the thing and worrying about
the thing thinking about the thing
protecting the thing and then when it's
all said and done replacing the thing
what's the actual cost it's it's way
beyond that price tag and last question
I asked myself I just came from someone
I was dating a few years ago she she
said every time she went into like a CVS
or a Macy's or something she walk into a
store and before she Boston she had her
impulse to buy something she said what
would Josh do in this situation so much
less she jokes you want to get one of
those WWJD bracelets just so every time
she could she
she went to the source you look at she
would say what would Josh do now she
didn't actually meant like well I look
up to Josh no she's saying Josh had
developed some mechanisms to be able to
deal with the stuff in his life and
really what she was saying is what would
the best version of me do and so that
that's that's my sixth question is would
the best version of me buy this thing
and when you say the best version of me
you're meaning the person who's asking
that question to themselves yes the best
version of myself correct which is
grammatically incorrect but that will
that will get the point across so what
would the best version of Kris or Nancy
or in this case Lexy what would the best
version of Lexi and her family do would
the best version hold on to this with
their future self look at them and say
why did I hold on to this why are you
making me deal with this now cuz you
know what Lexi isn't that what you and
your family are doing right now with
yourself you're looking back at your
past self and say why are you making me
deal with this you talking to your 23
year old self your 25 year old self your
30 year old self and saying why did you
put me in this predicament well now it's
time to to start anew yeah I think when
I heard this question I thought about
what Mariah and I did and we basically
first off we went through our stuff like
kind of at a surface level and just
collected a bunch of things we could
donate right off the bat I was like
Mariah I know there's at least like a
box worth of donating donation items
that we can pull from all of our stuff
like let's just see if we can fill this
box so that's where we started and then
as we were packing we were filling that
box even more and I know for for me
Mariah we kind of deal with our stuff a
little bit differently what kind of
stuff were you putting in that box oh
man you know old USB cables you know
shorts I haven't worn in a while
mariah donated some clothes a few pairs
of shoes just some stuff that like for
me I look at it like have I used in the
last six months am I gonna use it in the
next six months and that's that's my
rule Mariah I think she goes by a little
bit different of a rule maybe it's like
one year for her I haven't really asked
her what her ruling
yeah but but I know that she has her own
way of kind of letting go of stuff but
but yeah I mean automatically I'm like
oh this is this is a great opportunity
for Lexi to have a packing party and it
truly is especially if your family's on
board with this and they want to support
you like it can actually be a really fun
thing just just kind of packing
everything up and pulling stuff out as
you need it and then you say you're
gonna move in the next year so maybe you
do that packing party I don't know 60
days before you move and figure out what
you're actually using and then decide
what you want to do with the rest right
I'll tell you another thing Ryan I did
which I wish we didn't is we just
brought all of our furniture with us so
the way that Mariah and I got our
apartment here in Los Angeles is Josh
was so kind to come out here and Scout
some places for us and he would send me
some emails and and josh has really good
taste in in places and in dwelling units
so I totally trusted his his his
judgment and we do have an awesome place
but you know once we picked it out we
were like okay great looks like two
couches can fit there but we really
didn't like I didn't have you measure
the room but look at the floor plan yeah
and we brought both couches in I was
like this is stupid like this this
doesn't work it doesn't fit and it was
really clunky and long story short I
ended up getting rid of one of the
couches just sound them on Craigslist
for a hundred of termina bucks I think
that's a good point so planning the move
because you were deliberate about about
the move for sure but being more
deliberate about the space in which
you're getting ready to occupy that's
another great question that wasn't on my
list of six questions here but lay well
maybe it's sort of there right like like
can you afford it I mean you can't can
you afford the space right right for
your stuff and you don't have the space
here and so instead you can you afford
that it becomes cluttered accidentally
right the things that worked in one
house may not work in another house I I
think back to our documentary in the
architect Frank when he said I I don't
ask people what the thing on a living
room or dining room whatever I asked
people how they live their lives and try
to build a house around their lives too
often I think what we try to do is try
to cram an old life we try to cram our
pass
and one into our future homes yeah and
that becomes a problem yes oh yeah I
would I would encourage you Alexi to
just really don't make a decision on
what you're gonna do with your stuff
until your you have your place picked
out in Portland or in Seattle and then
at that point yeah use use discernment
to see what you will need and what you
won't need here's the other thing too is
going back to that question of can you
afford it can you afford to buy a new
couch or can you afford to buy a new
dining-room table whatever these big
items that you're looking at if it's
within your budget to purchase a new one
when you get to the city and you donate
the old one or sell the old one you know
that's that's that's okay
Mariah and I we didn't really have it in
our budget to buy a new couch so I tried
to cram the second couch into our
apartment and it didn't work right um
but yeah it's it's it's uh it's going to
be respectable on your part Lexie and
with your family on what does your
family need what does it really like to
do like Mariah and I we really love to
have game nights having two couches it
was awesome to have two couches for game
nights you know what we had two we're
gonna have to find out a different
solution and we have found out a
different solution for game nights we
have stools we can sit on we've got just
some other arrangements in our living
room that totally accommodate for our
lifestyle yeah so you can still live the
same lifestyle when you moved to
Portland when you moved to Seattle but
yeah you definitely will not definitely
but but you might not need all the same
items that you have in your life right
now to continue living the same type of
life you want to live I can tell you
with the move recently Ryan and I knew
this intellectually but really was able
to understand it emotionally or
viscerally with this last move moving to
Los Angeles because we've been
minimalist for nearly a decade now I
mean I kind of started this whole thing
back on my own journey back in 2009 and
it's 2018 now yeah and so it's
approaching a decade at this point and
we've learned a lot of lessons along the
way but sometimes we have to relearn
some lessons or sometimes they they've
they've just become part of our everyday
lives so we sort of forget the lesson
that we learned even though it's been
implemented into our
and and so I realized that the move is
the time that you were truly it's the
one time you're forced to confront all
of your stuff so if someone else is
listening to this the only other way to
do that is like to pretend you're moving
like Ryan did with his packing party
back in the day where you boxed up
everything pretended you were moving
even though you weren't because you
literally have to deal with everything
because you're not gonna be in that old
space anywhere you can't just leave your
stuff behind it's a piece I'm out if
someone else can deal with this right I
mean I guess you can't if you're a bad
person but uh but you're not you're a
good person Lexie and so you you want to
figure out what am I gonna do with the
stuff a few rules that you know well if
you're a longtime listener of our
podcast the first one is the 9090 rule
now we use this in my household all the
time used it the other day on a like a
pot or pan that was under our stove and
we've used it on a few other things too
where I'm like nope haven't used this in
the last 90 days but I might use it in
the next 90 days
let's see mm-hmm and sometimes we do
sometimes we don't and we have a
donation bag and we just put it in the
donation bag near the door and then once
a month Ella we make Ella drop off the
stuff and she donates and we obviously
take her down there and I wonder walking
once how they would trying to donate
some stuff at the goodwill right
attach a trailer you were like tricycles
yeah she doesn't have any more she's got
a bike man oh that's right he's got a
two wheeler put her it put all the stuff
in her backpack make her ride down La
Cienega or something but no so 1990 rule
is important for me and for my family
have we used this in last 90 days are we
gonna use this in the next 90 days and
if not we give ourselves permission to
let go I know I often say well I'm sure
there are exceptions to that rule I
generally don't have an exception that
rule myself I'm sure if that rule wasn't
work for you then you figure out the
time frame that does work for you also
the just-in-case rule man I cleaned out
my junk drawer the other day and it was
like uh-oh uh-oh
I've hold onto some stuff in here just
in case I was holding on for just for
win but it became apparent to me like
nope not gonna use that not gonna use
that my junk drawer is once again
pristine and
I feel cautious is like the most
organized junk drawer I've ever seen you
actually have a junk drawer metaphor no
I actually embraced the junk drawer in
our home we do have one junk drawer and
I embrace having that that junk drawer
there but I also have to catch myself
and say uh-oh like I was keeping some
things here just in case so I the the
rule is you can replace anything you
hold on to just a case for less than $20
in less than 20 minutes from wherever
you are doesn't just work in Los Angeles
that worked for us way out in the middle
of nowhere Montana when we were living
in that cabin on the side of a mountain
so you know what you it'll probably work
for you as well the cool news with that
rule is you don't ever end up using it
like we've used it five times between
the two of us in the last six or seven
years I think and so those two rules
really help me out
another thing that I would do different
going forward I would donate all my
cleaning supplies if I'm moving to a new
city that seemed like half the stuff I
packed up now granted I'm crazy OCD and
Ryan's always like just mess with me
like he'll text because I have in the
calendar like clean the house right like
I put it on my calendar and I have a
shared calendar with Ryan so I've like
texting he'll text me like enjoy clean
your house and I think he means it
literally because he knows that I it's
like cathartic for me to like scrub the
toilets or something actually scrubbing
the toilets I don't enjoy but I like
ironing and and doing the floors yeah
anyway I wish I love doing that stuff I
love it when it's done right well I
don't think I love it
I enjoy the process what you're saying
is you wish you enjoy it I also like
listening to podcasts a lot so it's a
it's an excuse for me to like put on the
podcast I'm listening to like Sam Harris
or Joe Rogan or someone like that and I
can just put on a podcast and lay and
and just get in the zone and start doing
laundry or whatever but the one thing I
had noticed when I was unpacking I had
boxes and boxes and boxes of cleaning
supplies Wow dude that's that's why I'm
and if I'm moving to a new city I can
repurchase those things but here's the
thing like I had a lot of cleaning
supplies I'm like oh oh I wasn't using
that in the last night
for some reason I wasn't looking at my
cleaning supplies as 9090 rule things
and I had a bunch of cleaning supplies I
wasn't using even though like I could
have used them and and it allowed me to
bring things back in when I moved in
this new place a lot more deliberately
and I have far fewer cleaning supplies
even though I clean the same amount now
right and it just took up way too many
boxes of stuff also with this this new
home that the Becks and I and Ella and I
all three of us are in now we it took a
long time to do this it was a bit
frustrating but I learned from that
frustration we slowly repopulated this
new home it wasn't about alright how can
we quickly fill this space to make it
feel like home I do want to feel like
home and it's important to me to have
especially the last few years we've
traveled so much and like because of my
health difficulties have bounced around
from different houses that I was
chemically sensitive to and man that was
so difficult for me and you you know
this yeah I I just felt like I felt a
sense of despair because I felt like I
didn't have a place to call home
and so yeah getting out here my
knee-jerk reaction was how could I hurry
up and make this place feel like home
and the the reaction remember in and
everything that remains the seat well in
the scene in our documentary to like
everything is crumbling down around me
then the line is but even while Rome was
burning there somehow time for shopping
at IKEA and I didn't want to repeat that
right even though Rome wasn't burning
this time around life was good and I'm
feeling really good right now I'm
feeling better than I have in the last
five years probably right now but it's
it's taken this last month to really
this is this new beginning it's it
really is a new beginning for me and
Ryan I I didn't want to just take that
IKEA moment say alright let's go out and
hurry up get everything and fill this
place up so I am complete right I'm not
complete because my house is furnished
or whatever and so we very slowly you
can go back and listen to our our
decorations episode was episode 119 and
Ryan and I talked about like sort of
putting stuff into our homes very
intentionally decorating with intention
whether that's art or other things that
bring us joy but I slowly populated my
new home
with the new me and so Lexi I think what
she can do is what is the new you look
like yeah it probably doesn't look like
the old you yeah what would happen if
you sold everything yeah this brought a
suitcase each how would you feel how
would you start all over again with your
stuff yes and yeah that's that's if it's
something cheek she and her family can
afford to do like that's that is a great
approach yeah especially because moving
everything across the country it costs a
lot
I forget how much I paid but it's like I
want to say it's like it's gonna be from
two to five thousand bucks and imagine
if you have a family of four or five
though yeah and I move from talking
I moved from Missoula Montana I think it
was like well it was like two thousand
bucks basically to get all my stuff
moved
uh-huh from Cincinnati it's gonna be a
lot more than that I know podcast Shawn
was looking into it and it wasn't cheap
it was not cheap yeah and so so thinking
about that well all of these additional
costs and to hold on to stuff that you
otherwise want to get rid of anyway so
get rid of it now so you don't have to
move it across the country and I'll tell
you this I for the first time in a long
time I finally feel at home I've
realized that this was amazing command
like and part of that does and so I'm
not against stuff it's about having the
right stuff the appropriate stuff having
the things close to me but not having
the attachment to those things either
I'm willing to get rid of any of the
stuff in my house if it stops serving a
purpose or bringing me joy I'm gonna
continue questioning it but I do want a
base level of comfort I do believe that
too much comfort is a bad thing but too
much discomfort puts us into a tailspin
of despair so we want to find the
balance what's the base level of comfort
so I have that right now um and by the
way I'm going to judge I just figured
this out yesterday I'm gonna do a house
tour of my house on our Instagram
account we're at the minimalists I'm
gonna do this on May 11th but it's at 9
a.m. Pacific time but it is only gonna
be up there for 24 hours that's the
beautiful thing about the ephemerality
of the Instagram live is it posts for 24
hours I'll just do a video answer some
questions but then it will be gone so if
you want to check that out you can do so
on May 11th that
as at 9 a.m. Pacific time live if you
want to ask me some questions when I'm
doing this we're at the minimalists on
Instagram and the last thing that I have
to say here is one thing that I did that
helped me out a lot I didn't like LA the
first time I came out here yeah I didn't
like it the second time I came out here
I didn't like it the third time I came
out here but we were here for different
media engagements or different things
but the problem was in LA it was me I
hadn't found the right pockets to
explore yet in - that would feel like
home right yeah and and because Los
Angeles specifically but any city you're
going to it's about finding the right
pockets Los Angeles is basic isn't one
big city it's eighty-eight smaller
cities right so whether you're in Venice
or West Hollywood or Boyle Heights or
Pasadena
you're gonna have a different feel and
so what I'm gonna encourage you to do
before you move to a place why not go
out there for a week or two weeks and
spend some time with your family there
what neighborhoods resonated with you
because you know if you're moving to
Dayton Ohio you're gonna have a
different experience if you're in Piqua
then if you are in Middletown or if
you're in the Oregon district downtown
Dayton or if you're in st. Ann's Hill or
if you're in right Dunbar like you have
these neighborhoods and Dayton that are
gonna feel different and what is
appropriate for someone else may not be
appropriate for you and so figuring out
exploring it maybe spending some time
there and thinking about it because
starting anew also means you want to
start from the best position possible I
think about runners when they're never
there when they're running a race you
know in the Olympics or whatever like
they don't just start off willy-nilly
like I'm just standing here know they're
in the position that that puts them in
the best position to win the race right
absolutely and so that's how Lexi you
and your family wouldn't want to start
off here I'd like to give you a couple
things here Lexi one is that that six
questions that I mentioned it's on our
website if you go to the minimalists
comm /q you can find that we'll also put
a link to that in the show notes but
Shana if you could reach out to Lexi and
send her a copy of our book everything
that remains the audiobook version if
she likes our podcast she'll definitely
the audiobook version of it or if you
want the book book version or the eBook
version we'd be happy to send you one of
those as well a couple things covered in
that book Ryan when I moved to a smaller
apartment I was downsizing I wrote about
that experience in that book in the 8th
chapter and then in the last chapter of
the book we write rewrote about our
experience of moving out to Montana and
then eventually into Missoula in a
totally different circumstance and
making that a home as well talk about a
new beginning yes
we've had so many new beginnings last
few years and a new beginning is that
doesn't mean it's the last new beginning
it's just one of many new beginnings
yeah I didn't realize I mean I get
that's why we moved out to Montana it
was to kind of have a new beginning but
I didn't realize how moving to a
different city like how much of a new
beginning it was cuz like I literally
got to rebuild my friends the the
hobbies that I had the interests that I
had so I think Lexi and her family are
gonna have an awesome new beginning out
in the Pacific Northwest and yeah good
luck Lexi Congrats on the move it's
gonna be awesome
yeah so maybe no final question to ask
yourself here Lexi is what does my
future self look like what do I want my
future self to look like and Ryan you
did a whole lot of that exploration when
we moved out to Missoula we moved to
that cabin in 2012 for four months but
then in January 2013 we moved out to
Missoula and you were in plays you were
with all these new friends you were you
found new establishments and new habits
and new routines and I became a
different life than your life in Dayton
even though you're the same person you
became a better version of yourself
yeah and that was through the experience
of the new place yeah it was well you I
was forced into becoming a new person
and you know I could have made the same
friends and had the same habits and I
was doing really well in Dayton I mean
you know changing those habits but when
you moved to a new place like you I have
to seek out the bad habits so right so
for me it was like it put me in a
situation where like I had to seek out
new friends
and really be deliberate with the kinds
of people I wanted to hang out with yeah
yeah it's it was great I'm really I'm
really glad we did it
and am I gonna seek out good habits or
bad habits yeah is another good question
for sure yeah
all right Lex I hope you enjoyed that
copy of everything that remains and
those six questions maybe print it out
like I have it printed out here and put
it up on your fridge ask those those
questions repeatedly I think you'll find
a lot of value in that all right our
next question is from Mary in Chicago I
have a question for Joshua I heard you
had mentioned that you lost 80 pounds
and I was wondering if that weight loss
had stemmed from an attempt to apply
minimalism to different aspect of your
life like dieting I'd like to just hear
more about that weight loss journey from
beginning to end what triggered the
weight loss how much does your lifestyle
change how do you maintain your diet I'm
asked because I've applied minimalism to
my once cluttered condo now I'd like to
apply it to different aspects of my life
like dieting and I was wondering if that
had anything to do with minimalism so
let's let's maybe not call it minimalism
to start Mary let's just call it
intentional ISM for a moment right
because that word minimalism often
connotes the the thought of just getting
rid of possessions but in our first book
minimalism live a meaningful life we
really broke it down beyond the stuff so
living the meaningful life was like what
do you do after the stuff and I think
the beginning of a new beginning for me
was regaining control of my health that
in fact in the book that's the first of
the five values that we talked about so
let's not talk about dieting either
let's talk about health that's so much
more important and and long lasting and
and ever reaching and what I mean by
that is it reaches out when our health
has improved then it reaches into all
the corners of our other law the other
corners of our life my creativity
improves my friendships improve and I
think the opposite is also true my
health declines which I experienced a
few years ago it hurt every other area
of my life
right absolutely and so Ryan you were at
the the at the top
of the show you were talking about the
the blood tests and and some of the
changes that you made and I can talk
about yeah I lost 80 pounds at one point
and well and they have kept off the
weight obviously but but I haven't been
focused on keeping off the weight I've
been more focused on living more
deliberately and and focusing on my
health not keeping off the way keep it
off the way to the byproduct yeah no
that's exactly what I've been focusing
on so yeah I used to be focused on how
much I weighed was like so much that's
like the wrong what that's like the
worst thing to focus on right because
you can cut off your leg and lose 70
pounds right it's really easy whose
weight if you look at it that way um no
I had to write a radically simplify my
diet I mean I we I already did that with
cutting out a lot of sweet so like like
like we were talking about at the
beginning of the show like it for all
intensive purposes like I had a great
diet mmm but it wasn't great enough or
maybe was a good diet it was it was good
but it wasn't great yeah and yeah to to
make it great I had to simplify it so I
just cut out actually it's not about
what I cut out when I bring into my body
now it's meat and vegetables like that's
pretty much it
yes any any any process stuff any sugars
like I try to keep that stuff out of my
body as much as possible I am not
perfect I totally had a bite of
chocolate cake three days ago but no
right but but the thing is is that yes
like it was just one bite so I've also
drought drastically simplified the
amount of garbage that I put into my
body yeah um I have yeah I have I have
really really I want it I want to sit
here and be like oh man I've lost 20
pounds and like I'm looking good and I'm
feeling good yeah you you better than
you have in years man but it's really
basis thinner you look that you look
more energetic you you you your
interactions I feel are more meaningful
because of it you you feel like a new
version of yourself I absolutely do but
it is it's not the weight though it is
it is the feeling I have yes that is
what that is what I really appreciate
about it because honestly like if I gain
20 pounds and felt like this I'd be okay
with it
right
I don't know if it would be okay with
getting to it but you know what I'm
saying well it depends on what the 20
pounds is right have a look at yeah I'd
have to look at some that's true I mean
if you were entering some bodybuilding
competition or something I mean you're
getting a little actually not getting
old for that bodybuilders tend to yeah
they go well into their 40s and 50s yeah
that's not what I'm trying to do but now
no but yes like but by simplifying your
diet and and it's not really it's not
really about like putting in these
strict rules as much as it is like just
following a consistent great meal
planner or a nutritional plan I say a
nutritional plan because that's exactly
what was instituted after the blood test
it was like alright here are the things
you need to eat you're the things you
need to avoid now it's easier for me to
fast than it is to diet so like I'm
allowed to eat quinoa millau to eat you
know brown rice like some slow-burning
carbs but I tend to stay away from those
things because it just makes me want
more simple carbs yeah so so yeah I I
it's I was very very upset when I
learned about everything I had to cut
out right well and the reason being is
early on we're having this conversation
you said I looked at it and had the
delicious bread or the delicious
potatoes on the plate and the way I
reframe that cuz I said things same
exact way is i reframed it to like I
can't have the harmful bread anymore
right
as opposed to Kasane delicious means
well I'm giving up something well I had
I really did do a good job of like
having these these it's not even a cheat
day it'd be like a cheat meal like I
never would have a whole day where I'm
like alright today I'm just gonna like
totally splurge and not count the
calories it would just be you know I
felt like I was doing a good job of
moderation when it came to unhealthy
foods yeah because dude I'm not gonna
recommend that any unless you're
allergic to dairy I would never
recommend someone go their entire life
without ice cream right like people
should have ice cream and live a little
bit every once in a while right and I
thought I had a really good
to that and learning that even that
balance that I had because of my genetic
predisposition but I was really angry
like man I can't even have like a little
bit and I guess I could like it would
have to be far far less but I feel so
much better now following this this
simplified diet mm-hmm
that I really don't want to go back to
having those those cheat meals now I'll
have cheat bites it's like when a cop
has to you know he they they taste the
drug only in movies but yes okay let me
try this anthrax yeah let me see if this
is cocaine oh oh that was Molly oh my
god so I could tell you there was a few
things that I did I think it was in the
same vein as you as Ryan here but I I
put two separate categories I knew I
there were some things I needed to
eliminate altogether soy I'm allergic to
so I can't have soy if soy is in
something it makes me break out really
bad it just it has negative up on you
yeah allergic to it right and then I
have sensitivities today I'm not
allergic we have sensitivities to dairy
and gluten pretty bad sensitivities milk
makes me break out like crazy so does
cheese but Nestle my stomach's a little
bit you stay away from ice cream yeah
yeah
what dairy ice cream yeah there are
plenty of other sugary treats that I can
have even at the pagoda on the salt and
stroll or whatever they have but some of
the best vegan ice cream they do yeah
but even then so I'll get to the next so
those are the things that I've
eliminated right gluten-free and dairy
there could be trace amounts in
something that I don't know about and it
will still just totally mess with my my
stomach or my skin I notice I'm like oh
like they didn't tell me there was so in
that it wasn't on the label or whatever
and the speaking of labels here's an
there's another category for me there
are things that I avoid it means I go
out of my way to make sure I don't bring
these in if they do come in it's not
going to be the end of the world but I I
avoid them at pretty much all cost so
processed foods sugar
anything with a label on it like that
that to me is like that that that falls
under the the process whose or the
packaged foods most of the time now of
course you can buy a pack of raw almonds
and it will have a label on as well so
it's just a good guideline for me like
oh if this has a label it's probably
something I need to avoid doesn't mean I
can't ever take it in my life but I
should avoid this unless I really need
to eat something so are these rules are
these the rules that you implemented
when you lost the the weight yes so tell
her to talk to the audience about I
guess how long did it take you to lose
the weight where you focused on the
weight yeah no I did in fact I didn't
know I lost weight for a long time
because when you have to live with it
every day so I've lost weight twice in
my life once when I was a teenager you
remember this up oh yeah I was literally
the fattest kid in our school when you
and I met in fifth grade I was the
fattest kid in our school and I just got
fatter after we met cuz you were a bad
influence on me and I was a bad
influence on you shopping double
cheeseburgers and each other's faces and
and but in high school I realized that I
was attracted to the opposite sex
and I should probably lose some weight
if that I wanted them to be attracted to
me as well and so I did a very unhealthy
way in high school I stopped eating mmm
realize that I wouldn't say I was
anorexic per say I ate one meal a day
but I saw wow dude yeah and it was but
it was junk food basically I didn't know
what like I'm gonna have one double
whopper yeah one double whopper meal
yeah I was radical calorie restriction
but I wasn't getting the nutrients I
needed some I was sick all the time I
had colds my immune system sucked but I
lost a bunch of weight and I knew that I
had lost a bunch of weight because I
remember one year especially after the
summer that I lost a bunch of weight I
came into school the following year and
someone saw me in the bathroom and said
hey do you know Josh Milburn yep yeah
yeah and he's like you
you look like he has a skinny brother or
something I'm like yeah okay like I had
lost that much weight
I remember did when I so we moved back
to Lebanon hmm my freshman year was like
I don't know a month or so before high
school started yeah and you came to my
door and you were knocking on my door
and I was like who is it I don't even
recognize you
yeah because I had I didn't seen you for
cuz I like had lived in a different city
for one school year yeah and have been
at least like six seven months since I
had seen you uh-huh
in fact I cuz I saw you once when I was
living in that different School District
right and you were just as big yeah so
like I didn't you know never even
occurred to me that you were losing
weight but I remember you showing up and
I was like who the heck is this kid
standing outside my door yeah I lost
most of that weight from the end of like
after eighth grade it finished so
beginning of right before the freshman
year start and throughout freshman year
of high school but then of course I left
and I just gained it all back and by my
early to mid-20s I was 240 pounds again
and I I mean I but I felt like crap too
and I didn't really understand what what
was healthful and what was what what was
making me feel ill and it took a lot of
sort of process of elimination and they
have these things called elimination
diets now I sort of created my my own
and so I learned that I was allergic to
soy and to gluten in the dairy so I got
rid of that but then also the sugars and
the packaged or processed foods I I
eliminated that and or I'm sorry I
avoided those things that whenever I
could I mean to me and then also the
simple carbs I avoid simple carbs as
well the exception that I make is for
white rice although I've been avoiding
white rice recently because I had some
higher arsenic levels when I did the
heavy metals testing last year and so
white rice has a little arsenic in it
there quite a bit of arsenic yeah so
like the arsenic in rice the mercury in
fish yes this is all this is all caused
by our damage that we've done to the
environment I know the mercury I don't
know the mercury is I don't know about
the arsenic I assume maybe it is but we
we plan
where most of the rice is planted
throughout the world are in as in soil
that is filled with arsenic and thus it
leeches and/or grows into the the rice
when it grows soda would just like we
would just build up a tolerance the
arsenic for meeting such a little bit of
artists name turns out it kills you also
in the movies
Ryan's over there like a cop Ryan is
like trying Molly a little bit of
arsenic tolerance is this cocaine nope
its arsenic no and so I realized I had a
little bit too much of that so I avoid
simple carbs and I feel better as a
result but here's the thing it's not
about what I avoid it's more now and you
Ryan you already alluded to this it's
about what do I put into my body I eat
mostly plant-based diet and fresh
vegetables but then also meat as well
and I know for me and it's interesting
we're gonna have rich role on the
podcast next week who's a vegan he's
able to live a vegan lifestyle that
works really well for him my diet is
mostly plant-based but I started eating
meat as medicine two years ago and my
health has radically improved as a
result and very few other things in my
diet have actually nothing else in my
diet has changed other than remove the
removal of a fish because of my mercury
stuff but I meat instead of fish now I
was eating fish before and so bringing
bringing meat into my my diet and
treating it as medicine yeah a grass-fed
non factory farm meat is is an important
way for me to not just get the protein
but get the the nutrients that I need to
make me feel like the best version of
myself how did you or when did you wake
up and you're like oh [ __ ] I lost 80
pounds I I didn't know until I think it
was because you didn't really maybe you
said something to me I don't remember
you saying something to me but literally
that kid in the bathroom
oh yeah his name was I think his name
was Shawn we were at Lebanon High School
in Lebanon Ohio and he he said and I'm
like I knew I had lost some weight he
didn't realize you were unrecognizable I
didn't realize how much weight I had
lost because I and
years I still struggle with it I was
still the fat kid in the mirror for I'm
not anymore
but I I was for many years and I think
that's partially why I gained the back
and didn't realize I was gaining the
back because I happened so slowly yeah
you know you don't you you're with
yourself every day so you don't realize
when you're losing or when you're
gaining necessarily but if you have the
habits set up then you're setting
yourself up for success so a few things
to talk about about here when we talk
about the five values that are in
minimalism live a meaningful life Ryan
it's really about turning those those
values in the habit so health
relationships passion or creativity and
then growth and contribution those are
the the five and it's about turning
those into two good habits so Shawn
here's some something petha for you I
know we're not looking for minimal
Maxim's yet but the good life is birth
from great habits and I know a couple of
weeks ago Ryan we were talking about
habits versus routines and and for me in
my own life the way I define these these
two things is I used to have a bunch of
routines that were decent routines that
aided my life but routines are shoulds
habits happen because there must so a
routine in my life could easily get
disrupted by a glowing screen or by
another emergency I put that in quotes
that weren't real emergencies right yeah
putting a fire out so to speak because
new emergencies are always around the
corner but I've developed some habits in
my life now that that won't be
interrupted by these so-called
emergencies because I won't let them
there must they must happen in a way my
habits are my daily emergencies it's an
emergency I must do this so so a few
things that I've done recently
especially since we're getting back into
a routine of daily life outside of
touring and I feel better than I have in
a long time because of it I feel like my
creativity is is rocket is exploding but
but also I'm taking my old habits and
making them new habit so talk about new
beginnings here Ryan some of my old
habits so every morning I like to write
and read and exercise right well I've
turned them into new have new habits in
the way that I
I determined that like let's take that
reading and move it to nighttime right
before bed that'll allow me to read more
fiction it's better to read fiction at
night because it puts you in a more
dreamlike state and the the the the the
the reading of fiction allows you to it
aids rent REM sleep right and so I moved
most of my reading to nighttime now but
the hour before bed and I then just
focus first thing in the morning on
writing for at least two hours right did
that this morning you know Beck's was
still in bed and I got up it at around
five fifty and wrote and then by the
time she was awake it was two hours
later and like we had our morning
together before a quick morning before
we we were before she dropped me off
here to record this podcast so writing
I've made that new even though it's an
old habit and then I exercised as well
this one I did I did my my stretch in my
mother physical therapy but also my 18
minute exercise routine which we could
put a link to that in the show notes as
well Sean so exercise for eight minimum
18 minutes a day if I were of exercise
more than that great like we're gonna go
to Runyon Canyon later today more
exercise it's a bonus but I've already
built in that habit I've made it my
morning emergency right but it also has
new habits that I'm trying out and not
all these will stick right they might
they might not want and and some of
these they might seem like big habits
like the writing write in for two hours
that's a big commitment exercising well
18 minutes everyone has 18 minutes come
on right but some new habits from me are
just 30 seconds so one is every morning
I get the first thing I'm doing right
now is I have a full glass of water with
a bunch of Himalayan sea salt in it I
was reading Albury Marcus's new book
called own the day on your life and he
talks about doing that first thing in
the morning because it helps rehydrate
you especially the Himalayan sea salt
helps helps rehydrate more than just
taking in the water so a huge glass of
water with a bunt and it's very salty
like like three grams of salt if you can
if you can tolerate it that's a lot of
salt right think about three grams of
salt but I feel hydrated I feel more
awake when I do that
right he also recommends light first
thing in the morning and and movement
first thing in the morning light first
thing them yeah I go out and see the Sun
for okay reset your circadian rhythm or
I have I had this little device that's
called the human charger because I often
get up before the Sun comes up so I can
use the human charger to expose me to
light as well it looks like an iPod it
goes right in your ears and then and
then you I mean you've used it while
we're on tour that's great give you a
little energy boost it reset your
circadian rhythm as well also helps out
with jet lag but the other thing that I
do is I've been trying out naps but I
also what Ivan sometimes it's really
hard for me to nap mm-hmm so I've been
trying meditation naps
remember in everything that remains we
talked about Collin right he has that 20
minutes of Awesome yeah 20 minutes of
awesome for him is like just sitting
down and doing nothing to sort of his
form of meditation just letting the mind
wander for 20 minutes well for me it's a
combination of that and meditating and
I'm sorry and napping so it's hard for
me to nap so you know I can't nap this
is another thing I got from Albury
Markus recently you just like put your
eye mask on and I put my mask on I put
in the brain FM which we've talked about
a previous podcast so it's an app that
syncs with your brainwaves that it's a
foots music that is that is you can have
there's several several different
settings focus energized one is for
napping right right so I put it on nap
and there's another one that's like for
sleep so you put your headphones in put
your eye mask on yep and I just lay down
on the bed and I focus on the breath for
at least 20 minutes I'll actually set an
alarm for 45 minutes because then
sometimes I was just like pass out I'll
accidentally sleep for seven hours at
1:00 p.m. and that screws everything so
I I will do that and it is like a new
beginning for my afternoon 20 minutes
now studies show the other thing he
talked about in the book was we don't
need we often think like well often get
eight hours of sleep every night and
yeah like in a perfect dream world
that's gonna work but we have
commitments we have all these other
things what we're really looking for 30
to 35 sleep cycles a week
and sometimes that can be aided by naps
in fact there's study there's studies
that show improved mental cognition so
improved cognitive activity more so with
naps then then protracted or prolonged
sleep right and so if you had a choice
to sleep seven half hours and then take
a half-hour nap later that's gonna be
better for you than sleeping for a full
eight hours that extra half hour nap
later is going to improve your cognition
for the afternoon so also it's a great
thing to do just set your lawn for 45
minutes I focus on the breath because
here's the thing yesterday I did it I
couldn't fall asleep mm-hmm it's okay I
still got eye I got what was very close
to REM sleep my mind's wandering and the
brain FM is going I feel like I'm in a
dream state and afterward I did feel
better what does your uh what is your
ordering what did it say I don't have
the new oral ring so it doesn't track
the naps yet I think the new I think the
new a so my the ring that I have is
called an aura it's a sleep tracking
device and I think the new version of
the app will be able to track napping
right now it just says I'm inactive
which I am inactive but it doesn't let
you know like what what level of sleep
you got to during your nap no it doesn't
but I think the new version of that will
come but yeah it does it just shows me
as an active but I can tell you another
nice benefit and expect this with the
little 20 to 45 minute nap is I have
improved sleep at night as well my
nighttime sleep is better it's like I'm
not struggling as much to stay asleep
not every night but I see a 10%
improvement and so we're talking about
making these little 1% pivots 2% pivots
but over time you're in a totally
different place when I'm yeah just doing
these small little victories the the
salt water in the morning the meditation
naps another habit when when Max and I
are in the same city I make coffee for
her in the morning and we just have a
quick conversation but and that gives me
fodder for the podcast but also gets my
brain going for the day it gives me like
other things
right down it gives me creative ideas
for the writing that I'm working on for
the next day I also do mid-day stretches
I was teaching these to Sean recently
and I think I've shown you before Ryan
but the one that I do I will set my
watch for every 22 minutes and I'll just
stand up here we we're here at the
office now we have this new table it's a
standing table we're both standing at
right now but I'll just do these arm
circles do 40 of these do 40 of them
backwards and do 25 of these
elbow-to-elbow things and it makes me
like it really loosens me up throughout
the day and prevents me from just being
stuck in one place I was talking to
someone about sitting versus standing
you know we have Kelly Starrett Spock is
sitting is the new smoking and that's
true but also like if we're just
standing like this all day my view and
our standing up straight knees locked
very straight that's just as bad for us
and as sitting and so the best position
to work at is your next position meaning
sometimes you want to sit sometimes you
want to stand you got Shawn who's
leaning right now you want to put your
leg up sometimes like this or you want
to put your leg down or sometimes I'll
grab the mic here I'll do like splits
like this right right and put myself in
this position and and move around create
that movement throughout the day so I'm
not just seated there you know it allows
me to to be a newer version of myself ya
know if you put your body in any
position and leave it there for hours
and hours it's it's not a good thing
it's bad for you yes for sure so I do
the midday stretches and then one last
thing that I do it's become a new habit
for me and it's working really well so
far it is not a fail-safe but I just say
no thank you
to myself like if I really want like I
want to buy a candy bar I'm really
hungry right now I'll go for the candy
bar now if someone else offer offers it
to me like yesterday Beck's
she had a piece of candy that she
offered me a piece of candy and I said
no thank you but I do that to myself now
as well because someone else is offering
it to me it's easier for me to say no
thanks for some reason I kits harder for
me to say no thanks to myself so I will
literally say it out loud
oh say no thank you that's great it's
like this trigger for me to just say I
can walk away from this I'm giving
myself permission to walk away yeah man
I know when I start compromising with my
diet that's when it starts to go
downhill really quick like there's a gas
station next our place that had this
awesome dark chocolate Lake I mean it
was just you know low carbs tasted
really good like one of my favorites and
then they stopped carrying that
percentage I'm like the next percentage
up was like you know just a lot more
sugar in there yes and I'm like oh you
know I'll just do it this one time but
I'm like now if I do this one time I'm
gonna do it another time right so I will
tell myself no thank you
yeah and walk away from it and yeah feel
a lot better about it if we're never
reason that saying it out loud really
really helps me the other thing I'll
tell you Mary is right the thing that
has helped me out a lot instead of
running from something have something to
run toward like what are you running to
don't run from the weight that you
currently have you're trying to lose
weight run toward a more healthy
lifestyle that's such a good point man
because it isn't a like someone who
let's say that like an obese person
they're so focused on the weight yes how
can I lose the weight how can I lose the
weight and the question is is how can I
live a better healthier lifestyle yeah
like that's the question that we should
be asking yes no one who wants to lose
weight cuz yeah I mean just going back
to that being the worst way to to look
at your health yeah your health is so
much more than a number that it's
displayed by a scale yes or your body
fat percentage now they're that those
are indicators just like the size of
your waist is a good indicator of your
health the the the weight on a scale can
be a good indicator of your health but
it's just an indicator it does not equal
health
yeah I might my good friend Josh Wagner
who is I mean you would look at him and
he looks he's like I don't know
40-something years old looks like he's
30-something yeah he is skinny very
looks very healthy just you know found
out that he is type 1 diabetic and it's
it just goes to show like if you
looking at just wait then he would he
would probably die very soon like he has
to look at his blood he has to look at
how he feels so forth and so on
yeah a skinny person could still be
unhealthy right yeah absolutely and in
fact there's the terms for that we call
it skinny fat right people who are sort
of like fat on the inside health-wise
but don't display the the outward signs
of the like you and I displayed outward
signs of being unhealthy right but not
everyone is going going to show that I
think yeah he's he's he's a great
example of though someone who looks like
a paragon of Health but but you may not
may not be especially it when you look
inside I mean my mom looked healthy she
was a smoker for whole life that's what
she died from and she looked healthy
until almost until the end I start going
through chemo and radiation and stuff
she look like she was healthy and and
thin and and but but there was other
things going on inside Mary's last
question here was about how much did my
lifestyle change it it changed entirely
I mean because it wasn't just my
lifestyle to change it was my focus that
changed my lifestyle because my focus
has changed I started focusing on newer
better habits I was able to create the
good life out of those habits so I think
if you want your lifestyle to change
marry it's about what you focus on you
will become what you focus on hmm I'd
love to send you a copy of our book
minimalism live a meaningful life shot
if you could reach out to her and send
her the audio book or the book book or
the ebook whichever she would prefer all
right Ryan let's well yeah we would love
to hear what you all have to say so if
you have a comment or a tip about new
beginnings or starting over or any of
the other stuff that we talked about
today including advice for any of our
callers leave us a voicemail for 0 6 2 1
9 7 8 3 9 it's it's my favorite part of
the show because at the end of the show
we air our favorite comments and tips on
on for more listeners and you can also
send a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm if you don't don't want
to call us and you just want to record
it right there on your phone you can
send it over to that email address Ryan
what time is a it is time for our late
where we answer questions from social
media we are on Twitter and Facebook and
Instagram at the minimalists during our
lightning round this is a Ryan and I
each do our best to answer each question
which is a short shareable less than 140
character response we also put the text
to these minimal Maxim's in the show
notes so you can copy and share our pith
the answers on social media if you'd
like and now you can find all of our
quotes in one place minimal Maxim's com
our first lightning round question is
from Becky how do you build self trust
to let yourself take the plunge and
create a new beginning well so if you've
lost some sort of self trust I think
it's fascinating because we can lose
trust in other people but I really like
Becky's question here because man
sometimes we can't even trust ourselves
right and sometimes ourselves or the
hardest person to trust mmm because we
know what's going on inside our brain
and our habits and our actions don't
align with the person we want to be so
my pithy answer for you Becky is
apologizing to yourself for your past is
an effective way to accept and let go
and what I mean by that is is sometimes
you just have to say I'm sorry and I
forgive you before you can move on and
to move on requires a certain amount of
acceptance of the past what has done is
done and then move on also you have to
be willing to let go of the past amen my
pet the answer is starting over requires
forgiving yourself and moving forward in
a way that aligns with your values and
beliefs and now when I say moving
forward I mean taking massive action
actions that align with your values and
beliefs Oh Becky it sounds like she has
lost some trust for herself so maybe her
actions have not been in alignment with
her values and beliefs now Becky it
doesn't mean that you create this whole
list of things for yourself to act on
tomorrow but at least pick one thing
that you really want to implement into
your life this is how I started gaining
trust in myself it started out with diet
then I moved towards a workout routine
and and other habits I wanted to to
incorporate in my life I didn't do them
all at once
I gained trust with myself with my diet
I remember
the longest time I was pescetarian not
because you know for any you know like
virtuous reason right I was pescetarian
because when I was eating meat like I
went to Burger King and got whoppers
like to meet with Burger once or twice a
month yeah well what happened is I would
I would allow myself to to go to yeah go
to five guys go to Burger King and like
just eat like crap and I would make
these exceptions so again it's easier
for me to fast than it is to diet so
creating this rule around being a
pescetarian I wasn't able to go to
Burger King and eat a whopper right now
when I introduced meat back into my into
my diet dude I haven't been a Burger
King once since I've introduced me back
into my diet because that free for you
in in retrospect the meat wasn't the
problem it was the source of the meat
the factory farmed antibiotic filled me
but then also what it was paired with
yeah the french fries and the bun and
the coke and yes it was it was a recipe
for a health disaster right and there's
there's a healthful way to bring meat
into your life if that's what works for
you and I'll be interested to talk to
rich roll next week because he has a
healthful way to to bring vegan veganism
into his life but he's not he is not
this prescriptivists he's not part of
the vegan mafia who wants to convert
everyone at gunpoint so to speak he is
someone who wants to educate people and
that's what we tried to do and educate
people in a way that says hey what is
appropriate for you and I even know in
my own relationship with with Becks
she isn't a she's basically a vegetarian
but isn't opposed to life trying meat
from from time to time because she knows
what works best with her body she's a
nutritionist she's been a dietician for
over a decade she understands and she's
one of the best cooks I've ever met so
she can prepare meat really well too but
she realizes what works well for her but
I've also realized what work I've
realized through a lot of trial and
error what works well with me and and
bringing meat back into my life was away
from me to to test out and and it was
disgusting at first I remember I would
like okay I'm going
have two little tiny cubes of steak like
this is these are my pills basically I
have two down these pills really quickly
yeah yeah no IIIi think Becky you need
to start with one thing that you can
help build trust for yourself
so if if it's diet great I mean for me
well dude when I when I really started
eating well I would I lost a little bit
of weight and when when you lose weight
your your standards start to get higher
hmm so it's like you know I lose five or
ten pounds and I look in the mirror like
oh well like I can tell us a little bit
away but then I just realized where I
need to lose weight everywhere else and
it led to this thought process where I'm
like alright dude like I really do need
to start working out and I've been able
to build this good habit with eating
maybe I can build this good habit with
working out and dude it has taken me man
it took me years to or three years to
get into a good diet and a good workout
routine I don't think I need to it needs
to take everyone that long but but for
me it wasn't until five years ago when I
really felt calm or four years ago I
felt confident in my my habits when it
came to diet and exercise yeah and what
I'll say is every time you so anyone who
looks in the mirror and they say I want
to put this habit I want to incorporate
this habit into my life and then they
take these little steps these little one
percent two percent you know pivots mmm
every single day and next thing they
know oh my goodness like I have I've
been able to put this habit into my life
like just one habit is gonna give you
enough confidence to trust yourself to
move on to the next habit yeah and it's
daunting the thing I'm going to try to
change everything overnight right and so
that's why people just throw their hands
up and never start right and for me
that's why I talked to briefly and it's
impossible to do that right right it's
yeah trying to change everything
overnight that is it's impossible so
there there is a timeline between
overnight and three years that it will
take you to change habits yeah and so
because changing everything is possible
overnight people throw our hands up and
they say changing is impossible right no
the change isn't impossible it's
incremental yeah oh that's pithy that's
good man
change isn't impossible it's incremental
alright Leo writes in when you're moving
to a new career there's always fear of
losing all the things you gained from
the past career yeah that's something we
definitely under face right totally how
do you tell yourself that it's okay to
not be in your comfort zone well so so
let me just answer that with a pithy
answer real quick and then I should've
got a couple here because he kind of
asked two questions right or had a
statement and then a question but that
seemed like almost two separate things
for me he talked about moving on to a
new career and that fear that you that
you have from from losing what you've
had in the past career but then he also
talks about my being in the comfort zone
right and so my my first pet the answer
is we needn't let go of everything to
move on you don't want me to be Ryan
when someone says you guys didn't get
rid of anything important well that's
sort of the point right like in fact I
brought with me all the important things
for my past career I developed a skill
set I had a talent that I was able to to
cultivate over the course of a dozen
years in that career of leading people
and teaching people and managing people
and also running a business I learned a
lot and that those are all things I was
able to tweeze out and bring forward
without bringing the baggage of needing
to meet our monthly sales goals and
deadlines and and and 3:00 p.m. status
updates and end of day reporting like I
didn't need to bring that baggage with
me because I didn't find it valuable but
I was still able to move on without
without letting go of all the skills
that are can you imagine if I said well
I'm just gonna leave all the skills
behind that I left No
why would you do that well no I think
Leo his the fears that you are his fears
that he's gonna lose all the things from
his past career come right and so and
we're here to tell Leo like hey yeah you
are gonna lose something from your past
career your status you're gonna lose the
salary you're gonna lose you know the
job title but you're not gonna lose
everything
right there are a lot of things you can
still hold on to you're exactly right
Josh and with respect to the comfort
side of things my my other Pythian
here is a life of surplus comfort isn't
a life well-lived Amen dude that's a
perfect lead-in to my pithy answer
comfort is the place in which we grow
and learn the least so comfort what that
does is it makes well at least for me it
makes me very complacent and and it's
not necessarily a bad thing but I'm at a
point in my life where I I do want to
grow I do want to learn more I love how
our message has has evolved over the
last eight years I look forward forward
to it evolving over the next eight years
and I wasn't and if can you imagine if
we were in the same place where were
eight years ago and just tried to keep
saying the the same thing like we know
we learn from what we learned from what
we've learned right Oh Sean yeah that's
a good that's a good pity one two but ya
know III think that leo he can't afford
to not be comfortable so I'm sorry he
can't afford to be comfortable yeah
that's what that's what I was looking
for yes um you know he's at a point
right now where he's unhappy but he's
scared to lose everything about to lose
everything he's built up well a Leo
you're not gonna lose everything and be
putting yourself in that discomfort zone
is where you're gonna you're gonna grow
and learn the most it makes me think
about like I mean that's with anything
with life even working out like that's
the whole process of the muscle
rebuilding you put your muscle in this
you're tearing small fibers you're
making yourself uncomfortable
yeah and that's so your your body can
build muscle on on top of that muscle
that that you've damaged and you're
understanding why you're making yourself
uncomfortable because can you met so you
know the pain you get let's say you've
worked out really really hard and you're
super sore the next day Ryan or two days
later however long it takes if you're
really really sore you know why that
discomfort is there right you feel good
about it now if you woke up one day and
you hadn't worked out and you felt that
pain that's a whole different story
you're going to the doctor saying oh my
god you wouldn't believe this terrible
pain well there's it yeah there's a
difference between pain and discomfort
for sure
and well and yes so know why you're
making yourself uncomfortable is a good
reason to do it and so I think about
about that Jim Rohn quote who said he
said that life begins at the edge of
your comfort zone mmm a little bit and
so it and I think the edge part is the
important part there we were talking
about this earlier in the show Ryan if
you go too far beyond the edge of your
comfort zone you're gonna feel immense
pain it's gonna be terrible you're gonna
recoil and you're gonna search for
surplus comfort but if you live there on
the edge of your comfort zone that is
where you're gonna grow that's where
you're going to learn that's where
you're gonna become a new version of
yourself
absolutely man I've got this essay by
Seth it's called uncertainty is not the
same thing as risk and I was really
looking for a place to squeeze this into
the podcast I think this is a good place
though because you know when Leo talks
about the fear of losing all the things
he's gained I think that is a it's a
feeling of uncertainty
yeah fear of risk the fear yeah the fear
of what is he risk
what is he risking to lose so so yeah
here it is often the most important work
we do doesn't bring a guaranteed
specific result usually the result of
any given action on our part is unknown
uncertainty implies a range of possible
outcomes but a range of results all
uncertain does not mean you're exposing
yourself to risk it merely means you're
exposing yourself to an outcome you
didn't have a chance to fall in love
with in advance a simple example the
typical high school student applying to
a range of colleges has very little risk
of getting in nowhere apply to enough
schools that match what you have to
offer and the odds are high indeed
you'll get in somewhere low risk but a
very high uncertainty about which
college or colleges will say yes that's
not risky that's uncertain it takes
fortitude to live with a future that's
not clearly in
imagined but it's no reason not to apply
another example if you speak to a
hundred people it's uncertain which
forty will be impacted by what you say
but the risk that you will resonate with
no one is small indeed the question to
ask every organization manager artist or
yourself is are you hesitating because
you're not sure the future will match
your specific vision or is there truly a
project endangering risk here
a portfolio of uncertain outcomes is
very different from a large risk so to
me it's the reason why I think this goes
well with with Lea's question here is
that he's not scared of what he's going
to lose he's scared of the outcome
that's going to happen from from taking
this new leap or taking this new this
new chance and to me like this this
essay is very comforting because what
this essay says is that if you've done
the work if you've done everything you
can it's ok to be it's ok to be
uncertain because you're really not
risking that much as long as you've
you've put the work in solely oh it
sounds like he's put a ton of work into
his old job so it's he has he has the
the work ethic he has you know the
habits built in this old job this is
something that he can totally translate
to another job now does he know the
outcome no but that's ok because he has
been putting the work in yeah yeah I dig
it yeah so so Leo I would I think maybe
it's time for you to take the risk
because maybe it's not a real risk at
all all right we got one more question
here this question is from Ben how do
you deal with people who project their
own fear and insecurities onto you when
you start a new life I usually ignore
strangers but what about close friends
and family well I've got a titillating
answer for this one but if you want to
hear our our answers to that question
you can listen to the PostScript for
this episode each week we publish our
PostScript episode over at the
minimalists private podcast which shows
up as
a separate feed in the same podcast
after using right now to listen to this
episode
the minimalist private podcast is just
for supporters of this podcast that's
that's why it's private right so if you
want to support our show and keep this
podcast a hundred percent advertisement
free because advertisements suck then
head on over to the minimalists comm
slash support in addition to our weekly
PostScript episodes the minimalist
private podcast also includes other
exclusives like our special ask the
minimalists anything episodes plus
unreleased recordings of all of our live
events we just put out the the DC event
this week I'm looking forward to
listening to that one because well it's
the one event that I wasn't at it was I
was crazy crazy sick with hand foot and
mouth disease and so I didn't wanna get
anyone else sick plus I literally
couldn't leave my hotel bed so Ryan and
Cal Newport who you all know from deep
work and and so good they can't ignore
you and then also uh Paul Johnson from
Canyon City who was on our hobbies
podcast all three of them were at the d
c-- event but all of our past events
that we've put up there as well we're
putting up a bunch of future events they
asked them in almost anything and then
also the entire back catalog of past
private episodes you can find all the
details over at the minimalists comm
slash support okay now it's time for our
added value portion this shows where we
each talk about something that has added
value to our lives recently Ryan was
added value to your life man I just
downloaded this album that you would not
like but I love it it's uh it is it's
Ashley Monroe it's an album called
Sparrow and Ashley she's done some songs
with Matt Kearney
yeah she's it's a she's a country singer
more kind of like a Dolly Parton okay
type singer but I didn't realize that so
very bluesy okay and this album Sparrow
is like I love it dude it's like the I
don't I'm not a country fan like I love
Johnny Cash in in like some of the old
country stuff yeah cash seems more like
Western to me I was like before the the
two sort of intersected right I mean
yeah he kind of falls in like that
southern rock had a category which to me
southern rock is kind of country as
tria yeah but there are very few country
stars I really enjoy listening to these
days and it's just because it's not my
job like I did in the country stars I do
like most country fanatics don't like
the country stars that I like yeah but
but uh but Ashley Monroe she is yeah she
just got this great awesome voice and
then she just does this great job with
the twang and the bluesy riffs and it's
it's a great album so she did the song
all I need with with Matt Carney he did
this acoustic video version of it and
she was on there singing with him and it
was yeah I can attest I haven't heard
her music but um her man her voice is
just unbelievable
yeah it's it's really great so I've got
three things we've got a movie a thing
and an album for you here yesterday I
went to go see a quiet place it is it's
it's under the horror genre I guess you
could call it and it's slightly scary
especially someone like Bex who gets
really scared
she's like Ella I mean Ella and Bex are
kind of the same person
Ella refuses to watch a movie she's
almost five she'll be five in about a
month and she refuses you that she
thinks all movies are synonymous with
scary movie she just like frozen we
tried to get her why she's like I can't
watch it it's too scary for me
but if Bex is she gets scared easily in
movies but it's there are parts that are
certainly scary and they're meant to be
scary but it's not like it's so John
Krasinski yes yeah yeah you know I'm
from y'all from the office and and Jack
Ryan and all these other places but very
talented after he directed it and Wow
cool it it's him and Emily Blunt and
their three kids and that's really it
it's only the five of them and the whole
movie but the this doesn't give anything
away I won't give you any spoilers but
the premise of the movie is there is
something out that is getting humans
killing humans and the only way you can
avoid it is to be quiet like to be quiet
all the time you can't talk he can't
make loud noises which to me sounds like
paradise there's definitely a metaphor
there yeah
well there were several metaphors la I
felt well but there's also it's like
hell on earth because they're the all
everyone's being attacked by these these
sort of like monsters for black of a
better term I don't want to spoil
anything but what's a monsters of
vaguely right and it's hell on earth but
they found a way to create their own
little heaven within hell so that was
the metaphor that really resonated with
me is like look I know there's chaos
going on in your life right now you're
listening to this and you're doing the
dishes or you're at the gym or you're
driving to work or you're in your
cubicle and I know sometimes it feels
like hell but you can create your own
heaven within that hell there's this own
your own corner of heaven inside a a
vast hell but it was such a great movie
was so well done Beck's and I left
they're like wow I have never seen a
movie like this it was the reason you
put it under the the horror genre or you
could put on a drama is because it's
it's is onra defying art mmm it fits
under all of the genres and none of them
at the same time and they did such a
great job with that movie so it's called
a quiet place it's out in theaters right
now the thing that I I'm not gonna
recommend but I got value from her
recently so I need to buy new sheets
recently and so quite often I buy that
with really nice sheets because I want
to make sure I've got really good sheets
that are on my body come sleep in there
eight hours a night and you know you
hear these commercials on other podcasts
and 17 other presidents have slept on
these sheets and I'm like well if
there's presidential sweat on my sheets
I definitely want them but I like you
you hear these in like you people were
spinning I've I've spent good chunks of
money on good sheets like it makes sense
to have a nice thing but sometimes we
also confuse cost with quality right
absolutely well I went I went over to
the store like to Target to buy some new
they have like a high-end sheet that I
generally get that I did I liked and
worked well for me but like I went to
the shelf and it was just all empty mmm
it was completely and I was
back-to-school or Valentine's Day or
Presidents Day sale I have no idea what
it was but they were all gone right well
and then the next one down the
if those were the A+ then like the a -
those were all gone to the beds so I
said you know what screw it I just need
something temporary right now
that's gonna work for me because my old
ones are just tattered they're done
I wouldn't bought the cheapest sheets
from Target that I could find yeah which
is not like me because I know they're
gonna be cheap quality or at least
that's what I thought mm-hmm
they're some of the best sheets I've
ever owned in my life nice I'm like what
have I been doing this whole time I've
been overspending on these supposedly
nice sheets and they've held up I've
waited for several months to talk about
these I'm like god these are great but
are they gonna hold out I've washed them
a bunch of times and they are still
great for me yeah whether or not they're
great for you I don't know but the
recommendation here isn't to buy cheap
sheets from Target necessarily it's that
hey maybe the thing I think I'm
splurging on I don't actually have to
maybe I'll get equivalent or even more
value from not splurging yeah dude you
you taught me to look at reviews before
I buy stuff yeah and that has saved me
quite a bit of money a lot because it's
like yeah you see option you know a plus
right and that is you know the best
option because of all these features and
you know whatever and then you look I
look at the reviews and it's like you
know three and a half stars for this
product and then I look at the you know
the substitute that's you know half of
the cost half as much and it's got a
four and a half star review yeah and
you're like wait a minute like you you
realized really quickly there's not
there's sometimes a correlation between
price and and the value you get but but
not necessarily and so yeah check the
reviews but also check what is
appropriate for you because my sheets
may not be appropriate for you you know
my sheets would be appropriate here is a
king-size bed and I have a queen-size
bed and so it really wouldn't work out
there right so all right oh one last
thing because you're using these new
sheets now if you want a great sort of
bedroom album to listen to I swear to
you this is like the best love making
music I have ever listened to artists
can't name black came out with an album
last year but it spelled with a six oh
six
uck are you familiar with them no from
Atlanta he's like a R&B guy but sort of
like the new R&B he has album called
free black and it is like the best
bedroom time music nice I like it makes
me like and I listen to all kinds of
like other like romantic music in the
bedroom I'll put Sade on or or Nina
Simone but like I was listen to this and
it was like it impacts was too she's
like oh my god this is a good album so
yeah you can now you can check that I
will put a link to all of those in in
the show notes if if you're looking for
those as well where are my notes Ryan
alright yeah it's time for right here
right now we got a lot going on in lives
of the minimalist so let's try to to
dive into a few of these things the
speaking of my partner Rebecca and
speaking of new beginnings in next month
so just right around the corner about a
week she is starting her next class the
23 day priorities reset in May so it's a
23 day class a daily video some coaching
one-on-one coaching sessions with her
but then also some weekly live streams
as well plus a whole bunch of other
course material she's been a dietitian
and a nutritionist for over a decade and
worked at a university for the last
decade as well and helping people
working them through setting up new
beginnings on their diet exercise and
life habits in general so if you need
some help she has only 30 seats in that
class so it will likely sell out I know
the other ones have as well but if
you're interested in that you can find
that over at her website it's minimal
wellness comm also we have a video
version of the podcast coming soon I
think that's what Ryan's wearing makeup
right now but you can find that you can
subscribe to it as well over at
youtube.com slash the minimalist as soon
as we have enough patreon supporters
we're gonna inject a video version of
the podcast so you'll be able to see
this we'll also do other video creations
with that as well next we've got rich
role on the podcast the following week
TK Coleman we're gonna talk about rich
role we're gonna talk about food and
nutrition and then with TK : we're gonna
talk about schooling and education and
careers and I already mentioned this but
just I've got a little list here I'm
going to do a Instagram lie
tour of my house now that I'm feeling
settled in and good it's it's not
complete or perfect but my life will
never be complete or perfect so I think
now is a good good time as ever to do
this
may 11th 9:00 a.m. Pacific time the
video will be up for only 24 hours on
Instagram were at the minimalists on
Instagram and have you checked out our
side project recently it's called
minimalism life you can find that over
at minimalism dot life I've got a new
essay going up there next month called
consumerism is the original virtue
signaling there's a lot of talk about
virtue signaling these days but I think
we've been virtue signaling or maybe
value signaling with a lot of the shiny
objects that we purchased trying to show
off and impress other people so I've got
a longer essay over there but there's a
bunch of other writings photos you can
follow on Instagram as well it's just at
minimalism life a lot of beautiful
photos they're curated by our friend
Carl and Alberto and we contribute to
that as well but you can find the
website just wwm innamal ISM life we're
also working on a new documentary so
Ryan we we filmed the talk in a
warehouse back in February
so talk we've given the last year and 50
different cities finally captured that
on video so that we could build the next
documentary around that earlier this
month we were back in Dayton Ohio and
going through sort of childhood memories
childhood homes we were in abandoned
mall where we got to talk about
consumerism and drive around a bit we've
got some b-roll for that we're headed
out to Joshua Tree next weekend to to do
some interviews and some additional
b-roll footage as well looking forward
to sharing this documentary with you we
don't have a release date yet but
hopefully we'll have it wrapped up and
be able to edit it the summer and who
knows maybe we'll have it out and
released to the world by the end of the
year it's called the minimalists les is
now and you can get details and updates
about that on our website if you're on
our email list over the minimalists com
a bunch of new writings over at the
website right now as well there's an
essay called who is this for
there's another essay that's come
this weekend called too weak to say I'm
sorry and the six questions I mentioned
earlier plus a bunch of other new
writings that we've been working on if
you wanted to show up right there in
your email inbox along with any of the
show notes that we always talk about you
can just go to the minimalists com enter
your email address at the top we'll send
you any new writings any new updates
about the new documentary and also any
new show notes for the podcast that we
release and that's all I got right now
Ryan you got anything else for us
finally here are some voicemail comments
and tips from our listeners hi it's
Chris from Barrie Ontario Canada and my
comment is if you guys are looking for a
good news source of unbiased that isn't
very full of clutter and garbage and
junk I would recommend a podcast called
the world next week by the corn Council
on Foreign Relations and it's a very non
biased great source of just information
on what's going on in the world and I
just think it's a great resource and
it's very unbiased and anyways I just
wanted to leave that little tidbit
behind hi my name is Helen I'm from
Vista California and I wanted to respond
to something I heard today about medals
and trophies I'm a runner and I had
collected 30 years of all kinds of
metals and recently just got rid of all
of them I did donate two metal to metal
that was one of the resources that was
given today but I also found that
teachers were very interested in them
trophies as well because they liked to
give them out to kids not necessarily
from the take home just as they're like
great job staying on task keep this on
your desk for a while kind of rotating
through the classroom so my teachers
that I knew took a ton of them and I
made several more into Christmas tree
ornaments because they do still have
some of those and then a tip that I
heard from somebody else for future is
when I get a medal at another race I'm
going to take a picture of it and take a
picture of myself with the medal
I'm going to give it away to somebody
else there's always families there
tearing on moms or dads so maybe a kid
who would enjoy it so they don't
accumulate anymore for me
hi guide is Josh here from Pasco
Washington really enjoy your show here's
a quick tip for students to prevent
student debt leverage CLEP exams that CL
EP from color board to fill prereqs and
save time and money you should start by
looking up your institutions Club policy
in the credit transfer section then go
to the College Board website to buy club
exams your school accept and find a
testing center many public libraries and
even YouTube offer free study materials
for the various tests as well if you're
active-duty military you're most likely
eligible for free testing through
dante's funding alright y'all that's it
for this episode if you have a question
for the minimalists give us a call for
zero six two one nine seven eight three
nine you can also email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists comm and if
you leave here with just one message we
hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time